merci à vous d'avoir choisi ma voiture
pour votre covoiturage avec plaisir ça
va être super broum broum super qui
s'occupe de la musique moi je peux
mettre ma playlist de musique médiévale
d'un corps non allison peut-être moi
j'écoute des livres alors ça c'est pas
possible au déjà 6 grâce à audible une
application pour écouter des livres
audio sinon j'ai aussi une playlist de
chant alsacien ok pour audible vous
allez voir c'est super simple et il y a
de tout des romans des thrillers il y à
plus de 600 mille titres sans internet
ça va être compliqué une fois son livre
téléchargé même sans internet on peut
l'écouter en plus il y a une option
voiture merci pour la pub est ce qu'on
peut écouter quelque chose maintenant
j'ai aussi un lien en descriptions pour
profiter de deux mois offerts il faut
que j'aille faire pipi on peut s'arrêter
on vient à peine de partir a les genoux
mais harry potter harry était allongé un
plat ventre sur son lit d'une lenteur
dans une main un livre relié plein cuir
ouvert sur son oreiller il s'agissait
d'une histoire de la magie a atteint
hier la sonnette merci c'est parti roule
ma poule où ça une poule c'est une
expression il n'y a pas de poule par
contre il y a un lien de réduction en
description si j'entends encore un mot
je vous laisse sur le bord de la route
messieurs dames comment allez-vous oui
je porte une chemise on n'est pas dans
pirates des caraïbes c'est une chemise
genre pour faire bonne figure au sein
d'une entreprise avec lorraine on a
découvert il ya pas longtemps qu'il
existait des séminaires en ligne c'est à
dire qu habituellement un séminaire
c'est des gens d'une entreprise qui
passe un petit week-end je sais pas au
parc astérix à disneyland qu'il faut une
escape game qui privatise un lieu pour
faire une petite soirée j'en sais rien
j'ai jamais faite séminaire d'accord je
parle d'un truc que je ne connais pas
parce qu'il est vrai pendant le coït n'y
avait plus moyen de faire de team
building on appelle ça je crois dans le
milieu de l'entreprise connaît pas les
gars j'ai juste eu un bac je fais du
youtube depuis dix ans je suis pas pdg
après avoir fait un faux d'entretien
d'embauché on va faire un vrai séminaire
tous les deux comme je veux dire je vais
aujourd'hui on est tous les employés de
la cuisine du string en séminaire avec
moi comme un bon patron je vais
commencer par tous les convoquer dans le
col
[Musique]
je comprends pas premières secondes ça
va pas attendre peut-être ces mois à
temps c'est moi vas-y parle à 1 2 un
assez bon jeu tout en haut c'était ma
faute est ce que tu es prête pour le
séminaire je suis prête pour le
séminaire moi et les autres employés on
sait tous concertés on est vraiment
content que vous nous offrez ce
séminaire à bora bora comme prévu donc
alors j'avais réservé tous les billets
mais à cause des conditions sanitaires
on a dû trouver un truc équivalent quoi
au hockey bon lolo iam pas on va faire
deux trucs chelous là quand même c'est
un peu improbable mais pour ceux qui
connaissent pas franchement c'est une
bonne découverte
je vois je mets une chemise ça me
traumatise garde ce à quoi ils ça manque
d'une petite cravate pour que ce soit un
peu plus pro si je puis me permettre
c'est la chemise de son beau père oui en
plus et c'était la cravate de son beau
père que j'ai perdu après la vidéo
entretien d'embauché
en route pour le séminaire en route pour
le séminaire oui
mais bonjour en chantier bonjour bonjour
bonjour vous allez bien vous êtes prêtre
sait ce qui va se passer on est prêt
puisque j'avais à souder nos lions
non non on va commencer si ça vous va
avec une première activité qui s'appelle
sacristie
c'est un voyage vous allez suivre et
interprété de grands mères qui sont très
sympathiques il faut être
complémentaires pour pouvoir avancer
dans l'aventuré au sein de la cuisine de
ce triste tous nos éléments sont
complémentaires bonne chance à vous
merci c'est gentil hockey play aussi
bonnes et lucienne moi je fais du chêne
battant c'est une décision qui se prend
1,2 au simone ancienne institutrice qui
vient d'emménager en maison de retraite
au grand dam de sa copine lui les mots
fléchés n'ont pas de secret pour elle
son plat préféré c'est la langue de
boeuf lucienne et plus jeune de cinq ans
ancienne infirmière elle a fait tout ça
car on hôpital public a gardé tout son
dynamisme son passe temps préféré chinés
dans les brocantes et trouver des pin's
pour sa collection moi je pense que je
suis plus du genre brocante et chiner
des piges je suis assez d'accord et
simone et le prénom de la soeur de ma
grand mère qui est morte
ça marche du coup de lois tuent valeur
simone et moi lucienne superbe allée
au le téléphone sonne timmons et
lucienne prépare tes valises on a un
concours à gagner encore cette année
sapristi lucienne heureuse d'avoir au
bout du fil mais tu sais bien maintenant
je suis coincé dans la maison de
retraite car mes petits enfants m'ont
abandonné il a vraiment dit ça ouais en
50 ans on n'a jamais loupé une seule
édition et ce n'est pas maintenant que
tu en as commencé prépare ta valise on
part dans la nuit j'arrive à 22h10 donc
elles sont en forme les mamies huawei
très être plus en forme que nous
sapristi ce n'est pas ma liste j'ai dû
échanger avec celle de simone j'espère
qu'elle va pouvoir indiquer ce que
j'avais écrit dessus ah ouais alors tu
dois me dire ce que je dois mettre dans
ma valise et moi je les dis ce que tu
vois tu dois mettre les choses suivantes
un mode et une brosse à dents de quoi
voir leur michaud sont roses des
chaussettes pour la belgique ok moi je
dois mettre quoi du coup je souhaite
encore de quoi il y en a quatre
chaussures de rechange dans sa cave en
identifie tu veux tu peux me répéter je
te plaît trijaud m et voilà me valut de
prêt fait ce mardi vers la voix pareille
est la même ok c'est bon en route en
route mauvaise troupe
au tu viens me chercher en voiture on
arrive à la boulangerie je fais le
boulanger bonjour madame le pen est
encore dans le flou en attendant vous
pouvez vous m'aider à vérifier les
stocks mais enfin un connard vient
acheter une baguette c'est ton problème
non c'est à boulangerie pardon donc moi
je suis face à aux stocks taqwa de ton
côté à on doit communiquer combien y
at-il de grosses brioche au sucre écoute
en suivant les dessins je dirais qu'il y
en a trois ok cinq citroën c5
3 3 3 ap quel gâteau rond en cette crête
sont au dessus de la brioche stressé je
crois que c'est des deux des donuts ça
marche de notes et au n uds tsa fait six
lettres maintiendrait des cookies et
alors bon bah cookies aux as oui c'est
ça l'image a parlé à attends je crois
que je crois que j'ai trouvé une faille
adam banon ont fait le jeu le gars
commencent pas essayer de hakim de
tricheurs c'est pas mon genre arrête
ok calais le goût du nappage sur le
gâteau roulé je dirais chocolat c'est ça
combien y at-il de fraises sur un gros
gâteau pas besoin que tu répondes je
vais à quel jeu j'ai pas besoin de toi
ma mère j'ai pas besoin de fait le
travail et en même temps quelle est la
couleur du nappage du plus gros gâteau
il doit être marron non il est rose et
je trouvais sens qu'elle l'est d'hilla
la la valade merci beaucoup pour vous
remercier je vous fait cadeau de votre
petit déjeuner bonne route à vous et à
bientôt merci dont convient de
travailler gratuitement pour ce mec
ouais et pour nous remercier nous filent
un pain au chocolat c'est du travail
spéculatifs ce alors m ouais je suis
remonté dans la voiture moi ok moi aussi
moi aussi elle vient de partir la
voiture
lalalalalalalalala tu peux arrêter de
chanter
sapristi je suis perdue chez plus où
aller ils connaissent pas les panneaux
ici amer ni stock de lire ça regarde le
charmant jeune homme je veux latine on
va lui demander notre route waouh c'est
le charmant jeune homme ok faut cliquer
sur la carte à bulles si j'ai bien
compris il faut partir de la case 8 pour
trouver notre destination il semblerait
que l'on puisse seulement se déplacer à
la verticale ou à l'horizontale mais
j'aime en diagonale pour passer d'une
case à l'autre il faut caler un point
commun alors du coup lorraine est ce que
tu me fais confiance pour résoudre cette
énigme oui je vais faire quelque chose
de scandaleux
j'ai trouvé c'était en âge 5 j'ai trouvé
ces bons à weight a trouvé grâce aux
indices ouais ouais en fait j'ai trouvé
tous les points communs d'une case à
l'autre moi c'était en h5 donc je peux
reprendre la route jeu
ok chouette je m'en faut arriver à sa
limite légale est championne sont
arrivés prête à remettre leur titre en
jeu achète toi qui peux dire ça ce
programme le concours a commencé on
attendait plus que nos vedettes merdias
neigeux qui s'est lancée j'ai cliqué ya
un mais deux jeux qui se lance pour ma
part
on a gagné sans rien faire ça fait tous
lorraine tu ressens ce que je ressens la
cohésion la dynamique là je ressens une
cohésion une communication une
augmentation plein de voix qui ça c'est
grâce à simone et lucette lucienne à
lucienne lucette +7 merci lucette c'est
incroyable cette fois c'est un peu
différent vous allez avoir une photo où
on a mixé deux visages de célébrités but
retrouver les deux célébrités qui
constitue la photo c'est le moment où je
brille dans cette vidéo vous êtes prêts
oui à lennart thy
nicolas sarkozy avec qui est cette coupe
la chine prévient patrice ficelles qui
présente le déjeuner la wii des jeunes
oui oui j'ai pas son nom mange tous
ensemble avec des charges et pas sur
nous parce que j'ai moins de 60 ans ne
fallait pas evelyne oh
je sais pas vous vous me donner quoi
comme réponse bas on va dire nicolas
sarkozy et
évelyne je trouvais l'idée yvelines jeu
j'en assumerai les conséquences et si
c'est pas et le blé mais c'était bien
sarkozy mais c'était sophie davant avec
moi moi j'ai vu la même chose à tous que
toi lolo truc de fou ça lui vient alors
ici qui aimons nous le temps s'écoule
vous avez déjà passé une minute si je
peux vous donner une petite
recommandation juliette se serait de
télécharger l'application faille sap qui
fait des feuilles swaps
stéphane bern chez stéphane bern et
alexandra lamy c'était la bonne réponse
comme elle est jaune
luanda
alain chabat et
rachida dati oui oui on valide on va les
excuser moi le jeu me rend fou je
deviens fou
et par le combat sera la
comen s'appelle ah je voulais son
nom et jean lassalle jean lassalle et
l'affichent dirais que c'est l'everest 2
minutes 16 il en reste bien doré julien
doré et bct laure manoudou avec
la suite maggie avec ses pages julien
doré non denses pas julien doré on va
arrêter de proposer des
c'est pas à melbourne c'était que nagui
avait j'avais pas m pokora est géniale
idée c'est johnny hallyday fin non mais
non mais pas
la trouvent bons alors c'était piaf si
c'est pas de johnny hallyday
à gérard jugnot est d'avis et valérie
damidot c'est une bonne réponse si vous
restez 15 secondes vous avez réussi
quasiment
on a géré on a géré le lot est ce que
vous pourrez rajouter dans le montage
julien doré avec quelqu'un quand même
pour nous faire plaisir
car dans quelques instants je vais faire
défiler des lettres il va falloir que
vous me ramener à l'écran un objet qui
commence par cette lettre dès que c'est
fait vous validez le point j'aime
beaucoup où elle est c'est parti il faut
cinq objets pour celui là la lettre
klich paix post it up la chao la suite
post it sur l île et chic est une pièce
ses valises et pochettes pochette il
faut chez telle une étoile c'est validé
bon voilà il maintient
une plante plantes j'ai jamais l'idée je
vous le laisse on va voir le record du
monde je te dis direct b basile mots
plus basile c'est un bel outil basile
régime baasiste il rallie les valider
bob à bâle une basket un banjo et un
banjo let's go les six vérités en face
elle suit ainsi cinq objets cha cha cha
ok ça c'est des
oxydes bien c'est pour passeport
excellence à cette augmentation soit
planète un casque et une chemise allez
ciao passe à la suite m 5 objets 1 m
vous êtes bloqués là aliments faut 5 la
mort 1 je suis mac masque c'est validé
un mac un mac valises et vérité le mac
tu en train de mettre le bordel dans le
bureau à une activité de cohésion de
leurs hanches et après un mégaphone ok
ok un muscle dur
ok ok de la mousse de la mousse de la
mousse à marianne un micro un micro
intégré microcéphalie de suisse à la fin
comme un coq géant à ok une agrafeuse
une agrafe aussi l'idée un appareil
photo est vanité de déjà lu qatar y en a
je et waqfs a photo un acte pas photo
c'est comme ça qu'ils s'appellent cela
et il en reste deux à avion ouais je
l ai plus qu'un une âme
si on va la gagner
dollar monte une peinture ou un dessin
dollars voilà les valides allez il vous
reste dix secondes un objet ou un seul
objet henry oui il reste cinq secondes
auger pas l énigme
wazi gg lorraine il est beau il est
magnifique bravo lolo squeeze et aurait
pu donner un peu plus un bon jeu qui est
bloqué alors moi moi je suis mais voilà
moi je vais je vais écouter vos scores
beaucoup dipj fait vous rentrez dans le
classement général de la croissance doit
être au moins dans le top 10 bravo le
rêve c'est sûr qu'on a gagné en tout cas
j'espère que vous avez
mon grave j'ai passé un bon moment je
l'annoncé légale est tombé en tout cas
merci de nous avoir fait confiance et au
montage et bonne continuation à vous
citer c'était chouette
on va à la lame et quelles complicités
on a depuis qu'on a vécu tout ça c'est
vraiment le jour et la nuit mais en tout
cas comme tu as pu le voir je suis très
très fort en quiz énigmes et où c'est
vraiment mon milieu c'est son truc ouais
je trouve quand même que tu as été
vraiment incroyable anarchie dans toutes
ces épreuves voilà je suis très très
fier d'avoir des éléments pareil au sein
d'un squeeze industrie c'est vraiment un
honneur et puis voilà j'ai déjà hâte du
prochain séminaire
allez à bientôt at remercie l'américain
débattront la boîte où il ya marqué
soyez à l'eau oui j'arrive à gérer
domenech oui j'arrive dominique pas trop
basse j'ai fait
bon messieurs dames j'espère que vous
avez passé un bon moment c'était très
très drôle de vie sain avec lauren qui
est très forte comme d'hab on fait des
trucs qui nous font marrer à faire et
j'espère que ça vous a fait marrer aussi
c'était très très drôle de découvrir ce
truc de séminaires en libre après on
sent que c'est pas forcément adapté à
des gens de notre âge je pense que ça
doit plus plaire à des gens un peu plus
vieux mais c'était quand même très très
drôle zones des conflits conneries avec
lauren ça me fait marrer bref prenez
soin de vous je vais acheter cette
chemise je meurs de show les gars
heureusement que je suis pas pdg pour de
vrai parce que si tu fais là
squeeze l'industrie se porte maintenant
à merveille grâce à ce merveilleux
séminaire allez bisous les suizo sportez
vous bien un gros bisou de maman
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]